[Musik]
dann kommen sie springen
können
[Musik]
was ich selber auch der rostocker
club demnach gäbe machen und wo das herz
dann auch eine brücke steht aber die
else du während und desto länger du es
nicht machst es durch die arge stufen
dass wir wirklich sehr zu von 4 578 ist
gibt es immer schwieriger oder und
hätten wir nämlich hat ja auch warum
soll man muss ja nicht aus der welt aber
eigentlich sind gefährlicher und eine
möglichkeit ist sich bestätigen oder und
das ist das war weg und die lockt man
kann gern einer strandbar wo haben werde
schon als kind hatte ich den traum die
dufourspitze zu erklimmen mit 4634
metern der höchste berg der schweiz
dieser traum soll wirklichkeit werden
ich will nicht meine höhenangst stellen
[Musik]
wir können auch weltmeister
wird
fabian moser ist der bergführer meines
vertrauens der hat sich dazu bereit
erklärt mir zu helfen
zum üben nimmt er mich mit indigo
schlucht sie liegt oberhalb von zermatt
und ist eine art kletterpark in
diese dunkle schlucht geht's jetzt
angleichen und
[Musik]
die platte good work
accenture noch läuft über das stromkabel
und zu bauen ist der bis bis
ich werde jetzt erst zeigen im moment
sie will ja nun sind wir ja nur hier
leute meines vereins bleibt aber ich
weiß das grundgesetz
gemacht was rund zehn jahre höhere
absatzvolumina walchhofer
und stahl korbel typische karabey
natürlich erstickt im gesicht das
grundthema wäre das nicht
passiert das ist
eigentlich schluss an
einem tag was passiert aber wenn alle
anderen passiert
[Musik]
katharina stoll pro block erste hürde 27
meter abseilen
[Musik]
das ist alles nur in dem kopf weiß ich
mir so klar november soll das neue logo
so dass eine wichtige säule steht jetzt
geld kommt fordert ganz gemütlich heute
hier ist das nicht sehr spezielle folie
zwischen andrea das mit dem sich später
fast
60 stahlkonstruktion jetzt
schon ja
ich habe immer noch
die befolgung die bevölkerung
[Musik]
nach schnellem wege sowohl
denn irgendwann ist
das ist ja das profil das wirklich dass
das
ist todesangst gehabt das hebt das hebt
das gestellt
die nächsten drei stunden geht's
pausenlos weiter
[Musik]
wenn das hier stehe ich ich bin
ja mal wie es geht
si
falsch
landtag
naja
[Musik]
ja was sie hat nicht
prof
[Musik]
man ist einfach bewährt und wir gehörten
bauen zu bringen sagt okay also ich
wirklich voll cool als ich einfach mit
elektro- und der kurs gehört aber extrem
zusammen
was ich auch die höhe
meistens können genießer weil es das
schöne momente wo es ist einfach
das leben hängt am seidenen faden zu
gunsten des favoriten
ich schlafe miserabel heute geht's
nämlich an den ort wo ich vor zwei
jahren kläglich gescheitert bin auf den
weg
der aufstieg ein traum genau in solchen
momenten spüre ich warum ich das ganze
mache die berge sie meine welt
smartphone-bereich alle sachfragen bis
gemerkt das ist eine exponierte berg
dass gaddafi und den gegner über das
klima toren dann haben wir
einfach status quo schweizer bischof sie
das ist
pleite
und
ja da wird es dann wieder gast und so
wuchs das ist ein wahnsinnig schönes
panorama und den kunden ins ziel das ist
der höchste berg die fußspitze mit 46 43
ist das nordend das nächste spiel denn
hinter der spitze
ich habe sei leute mich nie dran sein
wenn man sein aber am mini dänische dass
man bis an die grenze bringt und nicht
einfach derzeit okay dass ich zwei
wochen gemietet werden können und haben
ein bisschen glauben dass man dort
infizierte vertraulich beweis dass er
gehört die schon lange in der nächsten
station übersee strengen ich muss
längere züge sind bisher nicht betroffen
da drinsteht
einspurig gehört 1 1 1 1
die loks
pontifikats
der grat zum anna lena horne fühlt sich
noch genau so furchteinflößend wie beim
letzten mal
ja da gab es noch jetzt
gefällt ich habe
fertig war sogar der welt nicht sicherer
ich bin doch
ich bin einfach nicht wohl
wenig sammler dem nicht sammler manche
kann ich das lied dann nur noch
überprüft es ist
toll die mich doch
das problem und sind extrem hoch ist der
super gau also wollte ich sehen ist
vorne mitlaufen will publikum zu stück
geben wie der mobile und ins kühle wir
können noch nicht sagen
wie es ist ich kann nicht locker du
musst nicht locker wenn ich
[Musik]
aber eigentlich
wäre heute um 3 aber ich weiß nicht was
ich nicht dass eine jacke die magische
nacht oder minder stark
aber
genau
darin besteht kommt finger
das finde ich ganz mich schon da drüber
grund ist dass gott ja legen heute hier
morgen langsam ganz knapp das läuft gut
die schrittmacher für dich
langsam langsam langsam
ja ich werde ja ja aber jörg viele
machten am donnerstag die schritte horst
ihr habt ich meine
wird kein leichter schritt gehört nun
mal nicht passieren der v60 bringt
nichts das konzentriert machen druck
casino jack
ma es ist wieder ausleben und gut
ich es kann man nicht erklären was da
passiert
dass das leasing highway to hell oder
was auch immer ich bin da wenn ich kann
doch auf 21 cm aber wenn es doch in
exponierten naja es ist nicht richtig
dass ich nicht ohne
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht wie oft ich mich heute
gefragt habe wieso ich das alles mache
nur deshalb ich will jeden berg mit
meinen skiern erobern können
[Musik]
ich will noch einen schritt weiter gehen
und lernen meine angst zu verstehen
deshalb treffe ich heute die angst
expertin steffi wald in der
psychiatrischen universitätsklinik
zürich
sich mit der psychischen auseinander es
ist ja alles im kopf vor allem ein
gebiet nahe steht alles im kopf und zu
mal fachfrau tesco ist eigentlich genau
das richtige und manchmal arbeitet man
vielleicht mit seinen entscheid oder mit
solcher schritt aber ich freue mich mega
und und bin oft für die hilfe
[Musik]
die wahrheit
ehrbaren kury sie hatten sich gemeldet
weil sie sagen es gibt so eine komische
angst da haben sie den eindruck ist ein
bisschen näher als das üblicherweise der
fall ist optimal berichten was dann ja
ich denke dass vor allem weil die
eigentlich schleichen sich aufgebaut hat
und ich hatte die als kind nicht also es
geht ja um diese höhenangst bei mir als
kind wollte ich immer fallschirmspringer
werden ich bin auf hohe bäume geklettert
ich habe überhaupt keine angst denn
früher hat dass sie auch keine probleme
bereitet da sind sie solche skitouren
gegangen da sind sie solche bergtouren
gegangen ja ich war natürlich jürgen ich
habe mich einfach auf ein annehmbares
sehr exponiert sag ich mal in diesen
höhen und das habe ich überhaupt nicht
gestört ok ich sehe aber auch einen
familiären zusammenhang ich habe jetzt
sechs monate viele gedanken gemacht habe
und ich aber einmal erkannt mein vater
hatte höhenangst wir waren auch mal auf
einer bergtour in graubünden und da ist
er hin gesessen und ich weiß aber
kreidenweiß und mein vater im typ der er
mir gesagt hat sarah du musst dich nicht
exponieren dass es gefährlich wird das
ist eigentlich nötig also eher auf der
vorsichtigen seite und vielleicht hat
das einfluss oder nicht mein vater
forderung torte jahren gestorben und
irgendwie kommt da doch immer wieder was
wo ich mir das zu herzen nehmen was er
gesagt hat und versuchen gewisse sachen
so mir zu herzen zu nehmen der mit auf
den weg gegeben habe nicht so zu
entlassen ist gewöhnungsbedürftig ich
bin aber froh um die analyse und vor
allem um den tipp nicht der angst
bewusst auszusetzen
einer der teile der therapie die man
macht
das folgende mann treten nämlich nicht
nur sondern land leidet daran ist
im allerersten moment
passieren dass
es mehr das soll hat ihr das muss
passieren im sogenannten expositionen
oder was passiert dann aber oder was
soll passieren dass hirnen war gar nicht
so schlimm habe ich ja geschafft und es
erkennt immer weniger situation als
gefährlich und die angst langsam langsam
langsam ab so das klingt für mich nach
es ist wenn ihr bestes auch das ist das
ist ein training angst kann man wenn man
so will weg trainieren
ich muss jetzt erstmal alles sagten
lassen
denn es ist sehr sehr spannend und es
macht total sinn
und ich gehe jetzt wieder los auf die
berge ok dann machen sie das viel erfolg
für das gespräch
mit steffi worten im hinterkopf besteige
ich die nächsten berge hier bin ich auf
dem weg zum weiß wie's einem der 48 4000
in der schweiz
[Musik]
ich will ehrlich zugeben
so schlimm ist teilweise auch ist gibt
mir die exposition story jetzt eine
gewisse sicherheit
[Musik]
gedruckt zu sorgen dieser woche läuft
ich habe auch einen anderen blick viel
an vertrauen haben und
jeder schritt ist ein weiterer schritt
richtung wie vor spitze
ich will mich noch an das exponieren mit
hilfe von virtual reality können ängste
therapiert werden ein langjähriger
freund robbie hat einst auf diesem
gebiet geforscht und mehr angeboten bei
ihm ein training zu machen
[Musik]
libero mega gespannt
und mit langen mit der realität wenn man
jetzt auch simulieren und visuell die
immersion simuliere großen bildwinkel
drei strophen alles ist alles was fühlt
sich achtbar und mich und in die argen
stoßen kürze mit einem wirklich das ist
klar über die
allein für der unterschied ist einfach
dass du dass die banker und porto liegt
und rannten aber
trotzdem kircher der virtuelle als zwei
habe aber da nicht alles passiert das
passiert ja das passiert
ja ich habe das in ihrer angst ein
vorteil weil
[Applaus]
robbie hat sich schon in den 90er jahren
an der uni zürich mit virtual reality
befasst und sogar darin promoviert
[Musik]
wenn wir extra
die rampe
kanzlers und würde nein
du machst das gut so spürst du
die hand geld ganz schlimm muss es nur
mal probieren
ja aber es ist auch für mich ist das
wäre das ist jetzt viel weil das so
schmal ist und es ist also wirklich ein
update caillats und erwähnte kritisch
zu berichten
was ist zu tun wird gewinnt sie würden
ich lege mich aber das ist wirklich
wieder nicht
klappen kann die hand gott sagen
dass man sich so kann
man etwa die weiße stadt
dem er denke dass das so meri fahrt
wirklich strom ist etwa weg gebracht
danke
sollen quartal
beinahe wieder da und bekommt dieser
ring
und noch ein viertausender diesmal steht
die breite unterwäsche an
schönes jetzt darüber nachdenkt
sagt die angst mehr oder weniger
vacation dass sie das nicht glaubt etwas
das ist doch kein abbau wenn man
wirklich klappt nicht so einfach
mitmachen hamacher exponierter exponiert
jetzt leute keinen verkauf
werde warner music aber dass stress
weil ich weiß dass meine glücksgefühle
bald schwinden ich hier noch nicht
die top picks
ja noch nicht
machbar ist an einem seil
ersten schritt
muss ist das ist eine art ohne ja ich
weiß
spring-derby
therapie
was ist daran gelegen dass ich
[Musik]
schon ihre software ag
wo es hilfe schein hose
so müssten
wie die kosten
standen wir nicht jeder schritt
korrigiert trainings wieder gemachten
weiblichkeit
super
[Musik]
das beste ein ziel steht direkt vor mir
das
vorstellen
[Musik]
ein glücksgefühl ist wieder da mein
kindheitstraum soll endlich wahr werden
[Musik]
die für spezi wir kommen
das wetter war in letzter zeit sehr
wechselhaft nun ist aber klar heute
nacht war ich nach zermatt
[Musik]
noch ein letztes nach dessen mit meiner
partnerin barbara es kommt mir vor wie
eine henkersmahlzeit
notwendig machen beginnt jetzt aber das
ist auch das was die nächste gute chance
etwas mulmig ist mir schon wenn ich an
die dufourspitze denke
er ist sie eine realistische aber
einfach so dass doch blöd wie ist ein
unfall passiert sind schon verbot des
norbert
jetzt wo du am juni 8
ist in relation ja das hat der muss raus
das risiko ist größer als ein unfall wie
im auto jetzt sind
definiert gestresst als wenn du
praktisch
ist das natürlich ein dutzend kilometer
autofahrt dafür steht jetzt wohl
passiert wenn fahrlässig gefährdet ich
könnte jetzt sagen wir machen zum
autofahren muss in berlin einfach
relationen
sicher angst dass man hier die relation
verliert und das macht ihr angst
barbara redet wird immer wieder ins
gewissen wir leben seit drei jahren
zusammen sie kennt mich gut auch für sie
waren die letzten monate mit mir nicht
immer einfach
denn das kommt auch die unter druck und
dabei mit dem sport und mit gleich die
kolpinger kondition aufbauen und
das einschnitte geduldig stehen und wenn
es nicht gekommen
dazu haben unsere fehler erlauben
denn heiß und unterseite bin ich so
glücklich
und
naja
[Musik]
nächstes
macht
[Musik]
also in der regel
gültig ist
dahinter legen
die zahl betreiber doch ja ja
[Applaus]
ja und genau
der nächste kurs orten
zwei
[Musik]
welten nach und
so konzentriert wie heute war ich
während meines ganzen vorhabens wohl nie
alles was ich gelernt habe stecke in den
heutigen tag
dies ist meine chance darauf habe ich
hingearbeitet
ich will es schaffen
einfach glücklich gewählt und sich
bewegt und das macht es das einfacher
ist
warum
mir ist bewusst für routinierte
bergsteiger ist das ein harmloser berg
dieser wird still
stehen
die
queen ist megaschön
überwältigt haben sich angestrengt hat
sich schon explodiert da wünscht man
sich darauf konzentrieren
dollar
der beetle stehen
gut
si
[Musik]
sport1 wie
normale finale
den sinn wenn sie mal her gleich zum
gipfel was geht
es immerhin um geht sie doch du brauchst
nicht
klarer sein
sechstes punkt den der schweiz
genauer
[Musik]
für die sich seit 100 fehlen ist nicht
wenig so will sie
sensationell
[Musik]
ja möglich die letzten minute alles
geben ich bin in todesangst sie und die
haselnuss stau aber das heißt wenn die
mieter fasst sich kurz und haben
wirklich gute haben ich habe durch
zufall sei dass man alles helfer aber
das schreckt entschloss man sich mal
anschaut der muss einfach bereits sogar
das damals kölner und wenn man denn
gleich ich meine abbruch aber egal was
von angst geprägt das ist wirklich das
erste release und das ist der letzte
gewinn machen muss
das war setzte sich nun
konzentrieren
[Musik]